une fourgonnette blanche encerclée par
les squats tactiques puis prise d'assaut
c'est dans cette camionnette que le
suspect a pris la fuite
de suspect
le suspect s'appelle huken Tran il a 72
ans et asiatique
tout au long de la journée les
informations du shérif sont données au
compte-goutte on divulgué par l'identité
du suspect seul sa photo était publiée
pour quiconque avait de l'information
samedi soir 22h22 un homme ouvre le feu
sur une piste de danse alors que les
gens célèbrent le nouvel an lunaire à 13
km de Los Angeles
bilan au moins 10 morts 5 hommes et 5
femmes
j'ai vécu ici 37 ans 17 élus démocrate
jamais je n'aurais pu imaginer une chose
aussi terrible
l'individu aurait tenté une autre tuerie
à Alhambra dans la ville voisine peu
après mais des personnes se seraient
interposées en lui arrachant son arme il
aurait alors pris la fuite dans une
camionnette blanche
il est entré avec son arme à feu dit-il
mais des gens l'ont intercepté et il a
pris la fuite
la tuerie de monter le parc est la
cinquième en moins d'un mois aux
États-Unis et c'est la pire tuerie
depuis où valdé au Texas ici
Radio-Canada Washington